ces derniers temps les services
sanitaires semblent multiplier leurs
opérations de contrôle ce service
d'hygiène on vient contrôler les
cuisines et l'un des derniers
restaurants à avoir fait les frais de
contrôle sanitaires c'est un
établissement de la banlieue parisienne
problème d'hygiène et de décongélation
des aliments présence d'insectes
équipement sales dans réconcés dans des
conditions inadéquates face aux
nombreuses infractions constatées la
préfecture du Val-d'Oise a décidé de
fermer l'établissement jusqu'à nouvel
ordre l'établissement présente un danger
grave et imminent pour la santé des
révélations et des photoshops qui ont
fait bondir de nombreux internautes ça
me dégoûte vraiment moisissure insecte
mauvaise conservation les images d'un
restaurant ayant fermé pour risque
d'intoxication alimentaire scandalise
Franck capyro est avec nous communiquant
qui a géré le scandale des intoxications
alimentaires chez Ikea on se rappelle en
2013 IKA du retirer de ses cafétéria
dans 23 pays des tartes sur lesquelles
des autorités sanitaires ont retrouvé
des bactéries qui témoignent d'une
contamination fécale c'est à dire que
les gens en fait voilà
forcément puis voilà de l'arrêt au
gâteau
[Applaudissements]
s'agissait de gâteau appelé choukla
druer
on savait plus qui était le chocolat qui
n'était pas
c'était une tarte aux amandes avec du
chocolat
et c'est vrai que c'est vous qui avez
géré la crise mon Franck est-ce que vous
pouvez nous expliquer comment ça se
passe un contrôle alimentaire dans une
grande enseigne comme ça en fait quand
on est une boîte comique ou plein de
gens connaissent les meubles IKEA mais
personne ne sait que la restauration
chez Ikea marche énormément parce que
c'est la restauration qui représente
aujourd'hui le meilleur rapport qualité
prix c'est vrai que pour moins de 8
euros je vois à l'époque on avait un
vrai repas on fait plein d'essai c'était
de très bonne qualité donc quand on est
une marque aussi forte plus la marque
est forte plus la confiance est forte et
plus le retour évidemment bien entendu
va être fort donc vous devez être
totalement irréprochable donc quand la
marque est forte et qu'elle se prend une
crise comme cela puisqu'il peut y avoir
des contrôles inopinés comme on dit ou
tu es content même on prévient mais même
quand on est prévenu on peut très bien
être ou dans l'ignorance ou ne pas voir
les choses ou alors il peut y avoir des
accidents des accidents arrivent très
souvent il faut pas croire que c'est
uniquement de la négligence ou
volontaire parce qu'il y a des il y a
des fous n'oubl qui savent absolument
que certaines denrées sont à propre à la
consommation et qu'ils les mettent à la
consommation au quotidien c'est pas du
tout le cas d'Ikea c'était des accidents
il y a eu les tartes il y aille aussi
les boulettes et d'ailleurs les
boulettes c'est une crise que on avait
proposé nous à l'époque de communiquer
très vite ce qu'il faut faire pour une
grande marque c'est prendre le lit donc
encore une fois de la communication pour
éviter que la crise communique à votre
place c'est toujours cela il y a
toujours du déni parfois chez certaines
marques mais non c'est pas possible chez
nous bien entendu on est humain les
marques sont aussi humaine et les
accidents peuvent arriver donc un
prendre le lead communiquer avant que
tout le monde s'en empare et maintenant
que les réseaux sociaux n'en parlons pas
ça va dix fois plus vite 2 ne pas
rentrer dans le déni dire il y a
probablement oui puis il y a
probablement du caca dans les gâteaux
il a probablement un problème une erreur
et surtout montrer vis-à-vis du grand
public qu'on va tout mettre en œuvre
pour trouver le problème et c'est pour
une solution et en 3 surtout ne pas
avoir peur ça c'est la chose la plus
importante quand il y a une erreur
l'assumer directement parfois même aller
un peu plus loin devant c'est dire les
choses pourquoi on reprochera jamais une
grande marque une erreur au long
prochain toujours d'avoir menti à son
public ou d'avoir caché quelque chose de
minimisé et là ils ont fait le tien
c'est bon alors ils ont pour les
boulettes c'est extraordinaire nous on
est arrivé avait immédiatement quelques
minutes avec une réponse on voulait
passer dans tous les journaux une
annonce avec marqué désolé pour la
boulette sauf que là ils ont raison de
refuser pourquoi parce qu'ils ont dit
qu'une enquête était déjà en cours et
finalement sur les boulettes il n'y
avait pas d'erreurs il paraît qu'ils
avaient prévu aussi
encore une fois il y a deux façons de
faire on reste grave et on donne du
graphe sur du graphe ah bon on essaye de
détendre l'atmosphère nous on avait pas
encore
l'assurance qu'il avait un problème coup
de chance Ikea n'a pas eu besoin de
s'excuser puisqu'il n'y a pas eu
problème
d'accident grave et de gens qui est
malade vu Tony peut pas faire une
communication de l'humour bien entendu
moi j'aurais proposé un truc j'aurais
aimé j'aurais dit c'est plus Ikea c'est
ikka
tous les jours tous les soirs etc et
c'est vrai que ça avait donné une image
formidable à IKEA qui en avait bien
besoin à cette époque c'est entre 2011
et 2013 et c'est vrai que quand cette
histoire de de boulette puis de tarte
sont arrivés on a eu plus de facilité à
parler à la presse parce que déjà on a
une image plus sympathique et
deuxièmement comment prenait le lead et
en fait on ne laissez pas les gens venir
insinuer le fait que
Ikea planquerait quelque chose on était
offensif et quand on est offensif et
qu'on n'a pas peur bah ça marche on
arrive à rebondir il faut assumer ses
erreurs dans la vie en politique je l'ai
dit à des politiques pendant des années
ils écoutent pas toujours les grandes
marques heureusement elle l'écoute on va
alors ce que les agences sanitaires ont
trouvé dans la franchise chicken Street
à Garges-les-Gonesse donc regardez donc
ils ont reçu la visite des agents de la
direction départementale de la
protection des populations des DPP
les copains de la direction
départementale de la protection des
populations il y avait notamment
Jean-Yves Riboulet
comme un bon copain ils ont contesté
donc plusieurs manquements manque
comment c'est-à-dire qu'il y avait donc
des manquements des impressions aux
règles d'hygiène d'hygiène ça veut dire
bien sûr tout ce qui concerne
pas forcément bien entendu il y avait
donc de la viande décongelée qui est
baigné dans une eau stagnante
ça c'est chaud ça c'est chaud ça c'est
chaud ça c'est chaud il y avait de la
sauce avec des traces de moisissures
regardez
ça c'est la malveillance totale il y
avait des insectes volants dans la
cuisine
regardez voilà ça c'est alors on a ils
ont envoyé le Big les compagnies qui
m'ont dit un toralux
extrêmement puissant il y a des steaks
hachés conserver une température bien
trop élevée regardez
55 degrés c'est-à-dire le steak frère
ça va être la température de Daniel
Moreau
d'autres infractions ont été notées
locaux équipement salle non formation du
personnel aux bonnes pratiques d'hygiène
mais aussi denrées alimentaires non
protégées le restaurant est donc fermé
jusqu'à nouvel ordre pour obtenir le
droit de rouvrir l'établissement devra
se conformer aux normes en vigueur oui
ils ont détecté un danger grave et
imminent pour la santé et il faut avouer
que l'affirme a tout de suite réagi
Cyril et ça c'est bien parce que sinon
ça risque c'est ce que vous disiez
franchement c'est une firme dynamique
qui bosse avec plein d'associations
notamment en Île-de-France ils ont 50
restaurants ils ont 11 ans d'existence
et ils font ce qu'ils peuvent et ce
restaurant avait été contrôlé par eux
par l'extérieur et ils ont fait un peu
ils ont non excusez-moi ils ont fait un
communiqué tout de suite pour dire
qu'ils vont se séparer de se franchiser
il porte plainte bah c'est bien c'est
bien
d'emplois
quand on donne à manger notamment à des
enfants rappelle-toi buttoni
rappelle-toi des enfants qui en sont
morts d'autres qui sont dans des états
pas possibles et pour et à vie donc
excuse-moi fais pas ce qu'on peut dire
que la marque a bien réagi la
problématique des franchise le minimise
pas
quand on est franchisé on se doit
respecter une certaine charte bien
entendu des règles mais bien entendu
et donc on sait très bien que quand on a
pas indépendant bah les gens
malheureusement respectent pas les
règles et s'il y a des condamnations
dans ces cas-là qui prend c'est la
marque ou le franchisé c'est la
franchise responsable pénalement puisque
c'est elle qui met la nourriture à
disposition du grand public
alors qui contrôle les restaurants
comment ils sur quoi peuvent-ils tomber
on va vous montrer des images qui
donnent clairement pas très faim
regardez ils ont contrôlé un bar qui
fait aussi un peu de restauration mais
clairement c'était une mauvaise idée la
restauration tout est insalubre regardez
le bar baigne dans une forte odeur de
poisson grillé les policiers n'en
croient pas leurs yeux
c'est du jamais vu vous avez des
équipements qui sont inadaptés à
l'activité de restauration il y a un
réservoir d'une chasse d'eau qui se
trouve derrière donc si il y a un
écoulement au dessous il y a des
instruments qui sont utilisés pour faire
de la cuisson vous avez des poissons qui
sont quand même maintenant dans une eau
plus ou moins propre à température
ambiante puis regarder l'huile de
friture ressemble carrément à 2000 de
vie des pires établissements que j'ai
contrôlé depuis le début de ma carrière
et dans les Landes ils ont contrôlé
aussi un restaurant qui fait une
cinquantaine de couverts par jour mais
dès le début on entend le patron on se
dit qu'on se dit quelque chose il y a
quelque chose qui cloche regardez vous
avez des chambres froides
mais elle marche pas trop
comment ça marche pas trop
des nuisibles un peu partout
des phrases d'infiltration d'eau alors
là c'est la 400 là
pas du tout gérer en fait j'ai planté
mon thermomètre et on est à 17 degrés on
doit être entre deux et 7 degrés
Catherine a repéré d'autres denrées qui
semblent cette fois totalement périmés
on peut pas dire quand même que le foie
gras et soit très appétissant
regardez alors on pense beaucoup à nos
amis boulanger pour la plupart c'est
franchement c'est exemplaire mais là
regardez dans cette boulangerie insecte
température zéro hygiène tout y passe
regardez température de conservation
normalement ils doivent être
occupé et là on est à 10 et ce n'est que
la partie visible on a des conditions
d'hygiène quand même qui sont très
limites vous voyez c'est on peut pas
dire que les procédures de nettoyage
soient effectués il y a des cartons au
sol il y a des il y a des poubelles non
fermées vous noterez que les contenants
ne sont pas nettoyés les murs sont
poisseux au toucher j'ai même des
cafards attiré par l'humidité et la
nourriture les insectes ont envahi les
lieux et ils ne sont pas les seuls à
avoir élus domicile dans ses cuisines
insalubres et je pense même que j'ai des
crottes de souris
vous avez peur des cafards
des cafards moi ce que j'ai peur des
cafards dis la vérité est-ce que j'ai
peur des cafards
tu veux que je raconte quand tu m'as
montré un cafard montre un cafard il dit
ouais tu me fais chier pour ça un cafard
c'est pas non plus
j'en avais qu'un
chef tout à l'heure
il est venu gratter la piscine et
vous
savez comment il savait un vrai connard
[Rires]
automatiquement maintenant de lui-même
il a commencé
ce qu'il a fait